يبدو الأمر كما لو أننا ممثلون أو شيء من هذا
القبيل ترى دولًا أخرى تقوم بإجلاء
مواطنيها الذين يتوقون إلى
إظهار اهتمامهم بأنهم يقدرون
حياتهم ، ولكن بالنسبة لنا ، فإن بلدنا
مليء بالأعذار ، فلا يوجد مال
سيكلفه  الكثير هو أن
المال أكثر قيمة من الإنسان ،
حياة أربعة آلاف من مدن
المواطنين النيجيريين الذين يعيشون في السودان في سبيل
الله
رغم أننا يمكن أن نقول أننا من
خلفيات فقيرة كلنا هنا ولكن هذا
ليس سببًا.  لكي يتم تجاهلنا ،
نحن ندفعها حقًا ، لقد
بكينا لدرجة
أنك تعرف أن الدموع لا يمكن أن تخرج بعد الآن
تقطعت السبل بالجميع ، فلا أمل في البقاء
على قيد الحياة.
من أجل البقاء واه هؤلاء هؤلاء هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين يقاتلونهم يبدو أنهم
لا يقدّرون حياة البشر فهم
لا يهتمون بأي شخص
ونحن في حالة منك تعرف
الانكسار
حيث لا توجد كهرباء
لا يوجد  الماء كان لدي القليل من
الماء المتبقي معي ، لقد كنت
أدير المياه لمدة يومين
لا أستطيع الاستحمام ، لا يوجد ماء
للشرب ، لا يوجد طعام للشرب
لا يمكنك الخروج إلى الشارع لشرائه  طعام لا يوجد
لديك لا يوجد شيء يمكنك
شراؤه وحتى النقود ليست موجودة ،
فأنا دائمًا متيقظ طوال الليل
لا أستطيع النوم ،
فذهني ليس في حالة راحة وهؤلاء
الأشخاص مثل الأمس بالقرب من المكان الذي
كنت فيه  مكثت هناك كان
انفجار قنبلة واه
لذلك كنت أميل عبر النافذة
لأرى ما يحدث أن
هؤلاء الجنود يتجولون في
كل مكان وأنت لا تعرف ما إذا
كنت ستصبح التالي لأن
الحصبة تعرفهم.  إعادة
إسقاط الحصبة في كل مكان